there are devils among us  even as we speak the evil springs  i know there are many among us that  still leave bundles of bread and meat at  the edge of the forest  honoring pagan spirits minions of the  devil himself  do not for a second believe that these  acts are  harmless in truth every crumb you give  to sustained devils is a spat  in the face of the father does the holy  tone  not say that there is no true power but  the power of the father  his will must be fulfilled  tandia is it  have you come to pray my lady  there is so much sin in this world  none of us are free from it  i've seen you girl you do not fear the  father as you  should  [Music]  wish  we are many we are strong  we will consume this world we will dance  upon the grave of your decrepit goddess  you